seid ihr bereit für meine vielen süßen grip
cakes ich zeige euch dem video wie ihr sie
ganz einfach zubereitet und wie ihr den perfekten
grip hinbekommen also kommt einfach mal mit wir
starten jetzt zuallererst mit unseren vier böten
dafür habe ich hier meinen backpapier und meine
mini tortenring und wir machen jetzt folgendes
wir nehmen uns ist backpapier und tigers durch
vier weil dadurch dass jetzt die torten ringe
keinen boden haben das fragen wir doch mal ganz
viele nach nehmen uns einfach ein backpapier und
kleiden quasi den tortenring mit backpapier aus
damit wir einfach safety unterlage haben das auch
gar nichts raus weil raus gewinnen kann und ja
wir einfach da auf der sicheren seite sein meine
törtchen werden im durchmesser so ungefähr zehn
zentimeter seien daher einmal auf 10 cm einstellen
ich werde euch in die infobox verlinken genauso
wie alle anderen dinge die ich hier benutzte und
sogar überlegt dass wir so einen spaß erstellen
der haben soll macht das weil man schaffte ich
es halt einmal an und man hat es dann für immer
und meistens braucht man danach mehrere teile und
da ist so ein spaß hat eigentlich ganz cool und
jetzt nehmen wir uns hier einmal das backpapier
und dann immer in so knicken den bewegungen um
den tortenring herum und irgendwann kommt der
am ende an und merkt dass es halt bombenfest ist
so wenn ihr am ende angekommen seid einfach
an den ring dran knicken und jetzt könnte
das anheben und ich sagte ja es ist bombenfest
also da kann nichts mehr passieren und so mache
ich weiter mit den drei weiteren ring und danach
mache ich auch schon den teig dadurch dass jetzt
ein sehr unkompliziert des rezeptes habe ich
natürlich auch gedacht machen wir einen super
unkomplizierten teig ich nehme mir jetzt meine
ja die werde ich nicht trennen ich gebe ihnen die
schüssel direkt zusammen mit zucker und vanille
extrakt und dann werde ich das einfach mit einem
handrührgerät drei minuten lang auf maximaler
geschwindigkeit richtig schön hell cremig schlagen
handrührgerät habe ich an die seite getan
jetzt geht's weiter mit unserem teig schade
denn ihr wisst bei trockenen zutaten wenn wir
die unterheben immer mit einem teig schaber und
mit ganz viel liebe und am besten auch noch in
mehreren schritten ich gehe jetzt in meinem mail
einmal in meinen sie da kann backpulver auch
schon direkt dazu dann fange ich an zu suchen
es reicht jetzt aber schon dass wir ungefähr ein
drittel und jetzt von außen nach innen richtig
schön unterheben dann mache ich immer so weiter
bis die trockenen zutaten komplett aufgebraucht
sind so der teig ist fertig und jetzt werde ich
ihn einmal gleichmäßig einzeln in die torten
ringe das coole ist es einmal eine tortenring
halt so eine skala haben und da könnt ihr dann
genau sehen ob ihr bei allen ringen gleichmäßig
viel aufgefüllt habt ich habe persönlich nämlich
kein gutes augenmaß ich weiß nicht wie es bei
euch ist aber ich orientiere mich da halt immer
und guckt bei wenn sie dann gleichmäßig hoch
eingefüllt werden dann sind sie auch gleich
gleich schnell gar quasi und ich dass der eine
dann noch roh ist unter anderem schon gebacken
so die törtchen sind gerade für den backofen
180 grad ober und unterhitze mir ist wichtig
dass sie den wirklich komplett vor heisst
und dann werden sie für 24 minuten gebacken
anschließend bedenklich sie mit einem
tuch lanci vollständig auskühlen aber
wir nutzen natürlich die zwischenzeit
und machen dann die creme bis gleich
wir machen jetzt eine basic creme eine
basic vanillecreme die wir später noch
aufpeppen also auffinden mit verschiedenen
dingen während wir das ganze schichten und
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach eine große
schüssel gibt da sahen rein die sollte
ganz kalt sein ich habe sie ganz frisch aus
dem kühlschrank geholt und die sahne werde
ich zusammen mit seiner festen steif schlagen
und dann geht es weiter mit meiner mascarpone
sobald die sonne dann komplett steif ist machen
wir weiter in der nächsten schüsse ihr könnt das
ganze natürlich auch mit eurer küchenmaschine
machen aber ich wollte es einfach zeigen das
ist halt auch mit einem handrührgerät geht und
da habe ich jetzt hier die mascarpone drin da
habe ich auch frisch aus dem kühlschrank zucker
mit rein und wann der extrakt das ganze dann mit
dem handrührgerät wirklich nur zehn sekunden
rühren mehr braucht ihr da gar nicht und dann
habe ich wieder mit ganz viel liebe mit einem
touch aber die sahne unter dem ast ab ohne creme
die törtchen sind jetzt auch vollständig
ausgekühlt und ich habe sie einmal mit
meinem backform löser vom ring entfernt und
ich habe richtig knuffig aus ich werde jetzt
folgendes tun einfach alle hier einmal vom
backpapier befreien es geht ganz einfach und
dann nehmen wir uns einfach die torten säge
das coole ist wenn man einer tollen serie
die hätte eine echte klinge das heißt ihr
könnt da selbst frische törtchen ganz easy
durchschneiden ohne dass ihr euch großartig
zerbröseln und viele fragen wir wie das
funktioniert ich demonstriere ich das einmal
ihr habt hier keine stufen das heißt ihr könnt
sie stufenlos verstellen das liegt einfach daran
dass jeder boden individuell hoch buck das heißt
das gleiche rezept kann morgen heim zentimeter
kürzer sein und daher lieblichkeit dass man das
stufenlos verstellen kann ich nehme dann immer
einfach genial oder halt hier meine teig karte
zu hilfe halt dran cook wie hoch ich immer die
einzelnen böden haben möchte und muss mich gar
nicht festlegen auf eine stufe und dann geht ihr
einfach dran und schiebt bis hin und her wichtig
ist dass ihn mit dem finger hier oben bleibt
und nicht aus versehen hier unten an sitzt weil
dann verschiebt er die klinge wieder also ich hier
oben ansetzen und dann ganz einfach durchschneiden
die böden sind fertig durchgeschnitten die
creme ist fertig und jetzt gehts eigentlich nur
noch ins dekorieren und ich habe mir im vorfeld
gedanken gemacht welche farben ich mit welchem
grip kombiniere mit welcher geschmacksrichtung und
dafür nehme ich mir jetzt circa 1 4 denn die creme
reicht dafür vier törtchen einmal weg denn du
fertig also ein für die fertigkeit nicht ein das
bleibt schön weiß daher direkt einmal wegschnappen
spritzbeutel geben da werde ich gleich einfach nur
von die spitze abschneiden und dann bin ich da
einfach flexibler was das dekorieren und füllen
angeht so und die restlichen drei vierte die ich
jetzt übrig habe die teile ich jetzt einmal auf
da werde ich einen teil rosa einfärben den anderen
teil geld dann nämlich einfach lebensmittel geht
haben und ein teil in braun und da brauchte keine
farbe für könnte natürlich auch nehmen aber für
den geschmack könnt ihr da einfach bei cacau hinzu
7 und einfach umrühren und heftig dass auch brown
jetzt geht's an den schönsten bart in diesem
video wir werden jetzt alles schön schichten
und dekorieren ich habe wie gesagt ganz
viele verschiedene geschmäcker überlegt
und da starte ich jetzt mit den ersten zwei
und das werden fruchtige geschmäcker und ich
finde gerade außerhalb der saison kann man
frucht chips ganz gut leben das sind meine
fruchtig sie sind nämlich gefriergetrocknet
und die kann man das ganze jahr über snacken
die schmecken sehr intensiv daher braucht
ja auch nicht so viel davon ich habe super
viele verschiedene varianten die lege ich
erstmal zur seite denn für dieses video
habe ich mich entschieden für erdbeer und
himbeer und da fange ich jetzt einfach an
die torten jetzt mit meinem krebs zu schichten
und eben die frucht schützt darin zu verteilen
die zwei flüchtigen varianten sind jetzt fertig
ich hab sie ab in den kühlschrank getan damit sie
richtig schön durch kühlen und jetzt habe ich noch
zwei varianten die eine mache ich mit bananen da
könnt ihr auch getrocknete bananen nehmen oder
halt frische deshalb wird auch frische deswegen
stelle ich die gleich einfach in sehr dünne
scheiben und dann habe ich noch überlegt bei
dem schokotörtchen nehmen wir einfach ferrero
rocher das ganze wie immer schichten schönberg
verstreichen und dann müssen alle törtchen
für eine stunde richtig schön durch kühlen
damit wir sie halt für den trip vorbereiten
können sagt und ich darf jetzt einfach mal
die törtchen sind bei mir jetzt komplett durch
gekühlt und jetzt kommt der druck auf die torten
dieses video ist für alle die schon mein trip zu
hause haben ich habe nämlich capes ganz frisch
rausgebracht in verschiedenen farben und es kommen
auch gerne noch mehr farben dazu schreibt man
einfach in die kommentare welche euch fehlt und
dann nehmen wir das gerne noch mit auf und viele
mal gefragt kannst du mein video damit machen und
zeigen dies funktioniert was ist das problem bei
einem normalen grippe ich verlinke euch in die
info box mine gebohrt meine geburtstagstorte von
vor ein paar jahren da habe ich auch schon einen
schritt machen wollen ich wollte ihnen gerne rosa
er ist aber irgendwie in einer ganz anderen farbe
heraus gekommen weil es sehr schwierig ist einen
schoko trip quasi in der wunschfarbe einzufärben
und es ist immer wie eine überraschungstüte man
weiß halt nie wirklich welche farbe am ende
rauskommt so und beim eingriff ist es so
der ist halt gebrauchsfertig und der trocknet
ultraschnell das heißt er wird euch nicht weg
fließen sondern ihr habt wirklich einen schönen
grip und die gebrauchsanweisung muss auch ganz
einfach entweder für eine minute in die mikrowelle
tun dann wird sie schön flüssig hatte dann aber
auch wieder aus oder einfach in warmes wasser
legen für ein paar minuten bis es dann halt auch
wieder flüssig wird und keine sorge wenn ihr nicht
beim 1 bei einem mal das ganze verbraucht was halt
wirklich immer der fall ist ihr könnt es 34 mal
verwenden dann könnt ihr da einfach immer wieder
erwärmen und ich würde sagen ich würde dafür viel
drumherum ich drehe die kappe einmal auf jetzt
ist die öffnung da und wir können ganz einfach
hier am rand entlang herunterdrücken und immer
darauf achten dass der chip nicht ganz auf dem
boden kommt nämlich die geheime regel eines trips
also ich habe hier noch ein tipp für euch drückt
nicht zur veste und wirklich hier nur am rand so
ein bisschen muss runter laufen dass mir bekommt
schnell ein gefühl dafür wie feste ihr da auf
der tube drücken müsst aber meistens wirklich
so ein ganz leichter stoß und wenn ihr möchtet
dann könnt ihr gleich die komplette mitte einmal
mit dem grip voll machen oder in das ballast ist
halt wirklich beim rand das könnt ihr einfach je
nachdem entscheiden was für optik ihrer möchte ich
werde gleich nochmal getrocknete früchte obendrauf
geben und wie gesagt ist trocknet wirklich ultra
schnell bewusst damit die handhabung einfach ist
und der dritte nicht ganz bis zum boden läuft
für alle die jetzt bis zum schluss dran
geblieben sind habe ich mir noch etwas
richtig cooles über die ich wollte gucken
wer bleibt wirklich bis zum schluss dran und
passt wirklich auch und für diejenigen gibt
es jetzt noch ein gewinnspiel wir haben uns
nämlich überlegt dass es vier asse im shop geben
wird weil ich finds halt einfach superpraktisch
dann kann man sich seine vier wunschfarben
aussuchen und dieses set werde ich viermal
fünfmal aus fünf mal an euch verlosen also 5
mal 1 4 as it was müsst ihr dafür tun schreibt
man einfach eure zwei liebsten farben von den
cache trips auch in die kommentare und dann
erkenne ich dass sie mitmacht ihr landet
im lostopf und eine woche später werde
ich dann die gewinne anschreiben und das paket
losschicken falls ihr euch jetzt fragt wonach
die capes schmecken einfach schokolade findet
euch jetzt ganz viel spaß und nachmachen von
den süßen minijob cakes wünsche euch noch einen
wunderschönen tag und sage bis zum nächsten mal